One of the
fundamental theses of this course is that
in, in modern literature, and in literature
that isn’t so modern, there’s the notion
of a human-created monster, Frankenstein,
right, springs to mind, and at an adequate
time, I mean, Frankenstein was a, a fantasy,
an unconscious fantasy, a dream in, in actuality,
about the potential dangers of unbridled technological
advancement, right, Why is that? Well maybe
it’s something like this, and, and this
is certainly a, a notion that Jung would agree
with, if we don’t develop a moral sense
as conscious and as elaborated as our technological
sense, the fact that we’re increasingly
capable of becoming increasingly powerful
will necessarily do us in, right.
The bigger your weapons, the smarter you better
be to control them, and so maybe it is something
like this, maybe, and this is a strict Jungian
notion, maybe five hundred years ago when
we started to ratchet up the rate at which
we were developing our technological expertise,
and left our mythological and religious presuppositions
and conceptions behind as archaic and perhaps
as predicated on superstition , maybe we need
to spend as much time updating them and bringing
them into the domain of clear consciousness
and control as we have spent on developing
our technological sense.
If you were a medieval Christian or an archaic
religious thinker of any sort, your first
presupposition was that the world and the
cosmos existed exactly as they appeared,
which with you or at least your village or
town or country at the center, and certainly
with the earth at the center, and with the
cosmos as a shield around the earth, and with
the earth itself as the domain of man being
a fundamental attribute of the cosmos.
So this is a quotation from Jung, and it’s
one I like a lot because I think it adequately
and succinctly describes the distinction between
the way that modern people think, and the
way that people think if they’re still ensconced
within a traditional belief form, How totally,
different, did the world appear to medieval
man. For him the earth was eternally fixed
and it rest in the center of the universe
encircled by the course of a sun that solicitously
bestowed its warmth,
Despite the fact that pre-empirical people
had to deal with death and disease on a scale
that I think is completely unknown to us,
it doesn’t seem unreasonable to presuppose
that
there was a certain degree of comfort to be
found in a worldview of this sort,
right, because it appeared at least to the
casual observer that
the cosmos was human centric,
and that the notion that human purpose was
in some way associated with cosmic significance,
seemed to be beyond question, at least in
part because there were no theories of reality
that would compete with that initial preconception.
Men were all children of God unto the loving
care of the most High, who prepared them for
eternal blessedness, and all knew exactly
what they should do and how they should conduct
themselves in order to rise from a corruptible
world to an incorruptible and joyous existence.
Such a life no longer seems real to us, even
in our dreams. Natural science has long ago
torn this lovely veil to shreds.
how is it that people could think that way
given that it was so wrong and still survive?
Given that in large part we are necessarily
creatures of tradition.
How is it that we can sever the ties with
the manner in which our ancestors thought,
and suffer no ill consequences in result?
People think automatically, and, and I think
for good reasons, that
the march of human thought has been unbroken
progress towards increased rationality,
increased power, increased clarity, but it’s
certainly the case that as a consequence of
sacrifice of our religious beliefs
and our philosophical beliefs that problems
of meaning have become more paramount for
the modern person.
And then you might ask, well what exactly
are the consequences of that,
and I think initially the best perspective
to take is one that’s historical.
As we’ve moved away from a classical, mystical
or mythological worldview,
a number of dramatic occurrences have unfolded,
we’ve become much more technologically powerful,
right.
The application of a strict empirical model
designed to abstract out from everyone’s
experience,
those things that are material and constant
have enabled us to produce
technological implements of extreme power,
right, both for good, at least in principle
with regards to medical advances,
and also for ill, in terms of our ability
to control weapons of unbelievable destructive
force.
So we’re more powerful. Are we any smarter
or any wiser?
Well I think a casual glance at the history
of the 20th Century would suggest that perhaps
we’re not.
I don’t think there’s any indication whatsoever,
although perhaps things have improved in the
last fifteen years,
that an additional consequence of our capacity
to extract ourselves from our religious modes
of thought
has been a palpable increase in wisdom or
tolerance or compassion,
or a palpable increase in our ability to understand
explicitly what might constitute the basis
for a suitable and stable state.
So you might take, for example, the fact that
the 20th Century has been unbelievably bloody,
right, literally hundreds of millions of people
killed in conflicts of one form or another,
both external, say, in the course of World
War II or Vietnam,
and internal, in the case of Nazi Germany
or the Soviet Union,
or any of the vast array of countries who
subjected their citizens to terrible internal
repression
in the name of the maintenance of order.
I mentioned that Alexander Solzhenitzyn estimated
that
sixty million people died in the Soviet Union
between 1919 and 1959
as a consequence of internal repression,
and his estimates were that perhaps twice
that many died during the Cultural Revolution
in China.
Looking back on the 20th Century, one seem,
one thing seems relatively clear, right.
Although humanity as a whole has ceased, or
had ceased at least to engage in large scale
religious conflicts,
although they seem to have been making a vicious
comeback in the last five years,
our ability to live together still seems incredibly
compromised by our capacity to engage in ideological
conflict, right,
and it doesn’t seem to me ridiculous to
presume that the battles between capitalism
and communism, say,
or between capitalism, communism and fascism
, or even the emergent struggle between fundamentalist
Islam and the West,
can necessarily be regarded as anything but
extensions of our tendency towards religious
and mythological conflict,
even though, in principle, systems like communism
and fascism were not predicated on explicitly
religious presuppositions.
Well it seems to me that a logical conclusion
from observations of that sort
is that even if you eradicate the traditional
trappings of the mythological worldview,
which seems to be what’s happened as a consequence
of our rise in empirical knowledge,
that you don’t eradicate the tendency for
people to formulate groups, belief systems
, around conceptions of ways that you should
behave
that are, at the very least, religious in
structure and action, even if they’re not
religious in name;
I mean I think it’s a very peculiar coincidence,
for example,
that the Soviet Communists erected at Male
Trinity
Marx, Lenin and Stalin as an apparent replacement
for the masculine trinity
that comprised the essential deities of Orthodox,
Russian Orthodox Christianity.
Why would these forms re-emerge so spontaneously,
and what does it mean that people who regard
themselves as essentially modern and empirical
in their presuppositions seem to be absolutely
susceptible in their fundament to ideological
claims?
Well if you look at the Soviet Union, which
I think is a very instructive case
because the Soviets, the Russians, were really
the last European power to fall prey to the
conflict
between empiricism and science and religion,
and they didn’t really fall prey to that
until the mid 1800’s
because Russia was a relatively closed society,
relatively illiterate,
maintaining a medieval structure far past
the time when other European countries had
abandoned that.
In the 1850’s, a wave of atheism spread
across Russia,
in some sense as a wave of enlightenment,
but also as a plague,
and figures as powering as Tolstoy
remembered in his memoirs the very day that
he realized
that the empirical discoveries of Western
Europeans had eradicated his ability to believe
in the Russian Orthodox system.
You lose something like that, what happens?
Well if you believe that mythological thinking
is nothing but superstitious empiricism
and that it’s been replaced entirely by
a more appropriate modern view, then nothing
happens, right,
it’s all to your benefit to become enlightened,
but if you believe that there’s more to
the story than that,
and that more traditional, ethical and moral
systems predicated on mythological presuppositions
offer you a map of how to behave and what
to think and how to regulate your emotions
and what to strive for,
none of which can be replaced by a scientific
perspective, then the eradication of a system
like that leaves a vacuum,
and then the question is, what rushes in to
fill a vacuum?
Well if you look at the case of the Soviet
Union, it seems quite instructive, doesn’t
it.
I mean, there’s a thirty-year period where
there’s tremendous intellectual clash,
say between a materialist, an empirical perspective,
and in Russian Orthodox perspective.
The Russian Orthodox perspective loses its
attractiveness for the reigning intellectual
elite
and the presuppositions of communism which
appear rational by contrast,
but which, by all evidence, were not, rush
in to fill the gap, and
I want to read you something that Nietzsche
wrote, it’s perhaps the most famous thing
he ever said,
although it’s almost entirely taken out
of context and misquoted, and if not misquoted,
at least misunderstood,
because Nietzsche was one of these strange
people who was capable of living 50 or even
100 years into the future,
and although he was, is, generally regarded
as an enemy of Christianity and superstition,
and was certainly an unbelievably outspoken
of Christian… opponent of Christian traditionalism,
How similar. Don’t know exactly how similar
but that’s what stories tell you how similar.
One of the fundamental theses of this course
is that in, in modern literature, and in literature
that isn’t so modern, there’s the notion
of a human-created monster, Frankenstein,
right, springs to mind, and at an adequate
time, I mean, Frankenstein was a, a fantasy,
an unconscious fantasy, a dream in, in actuality,
about the potential dangers of unbridled technological
advancement, right, Why is that? Well maybe
it’s something like this, and, and this
is certainly a, a notion that Jung would agree
with, if we don’t develop a moral sense
as conscious and as elaborated as our technological
sense, the fact that we’re increasingly
capable of becoming increasingly powerful
will necessarily do us in, right.
The bigger your weapons, the smarter you better
be to control them, and so maybe it is something
like this, maybe, and this is a strict Jungian
notion, maybe five hundred years ago when
we started to ratchet up the rate at which
we were developing our technological expertise,
and left our mythological and religious presuppositions
and conceptions behind as archaic and perhaps
as predicated on superstition , maybe we need
to spend as much time updating them and bringing
them into the domain of clear consciousness
and control as we have spent on developing
our technological sense.
If you were a medieval Christian or an archaic
religious thinker of any sort, your first
presupposition was that the world and the
cosmos existed exactly as they appeared,
which with you or at least your village or
town or country at the center, and certainly
with the earth at the center, and with the
cosmos as a shield around the earth, and with
the earth itself as the domain of man being
a fundamental attribute of the cosmos.
So this is a quotation from Jung, and it’s
one I like a lot because I think it adequately
and succinctly describes the distinction between
the way that modern people think, and the
way that people think if they’re still ensconced
within a traditional belief form, How totally,
different, did the world appear to medieval
man. For him the earth was eternally fixed
and it rest in the center of the universe
encircled by the course of a sun that solicitously
bestowed its warmth,
Despite the fact that pre-empirical people
had to deal with death and disease on a scale
that I think is completely unknown to us,
it doesn’t seem unreasonable to presuppose
that
there was a certain degree of comfort to be
found in a worldview of this sort,
right, because it appeared at least to the
casual observer that
the cosmos was human centric,
and that the notion that human purpose was
in some way associated with cosmic significance,
seemed to be beyond question, at least in
part because there were no theories of reality
that would compete with that initial preconception.
Men were all children of God unto the loving
care of the most High, who prepared them for
eternal blessedness, and all knew exactly
what they should do and how they should conduct
themselves in order to rise from a corruptible
world to an incorruptible and joyous existence.
Such a life no longer seems real to us, even
in our dreams. Natural science has long ago
torn this lovely veil to shreds.
how is it that people could think that way
given that it was so wrong and still survive?
Given that in large part we are necessarily
creatures of tradition.
How is it that we can sever the ties with
the manner in which our ancestors thought,
and suffer no ill consequences in result?
People think automatically, and, and I think
for good reasons, that
the march of human thought has been unbroken
progress towards increased rationality,
increased power, increased clarity, but it’s
certainly the case that as a consequence of
sacrifice of our religious beliefs
and our philosophical beliefs that problems
of meaning have become more paramount for
the modern person.
And then you might ask, well what exactly
are the consequences of that,
and I think initially the best perspective
to take is one that’s historical.
As we’ve moved away from a classical, mystical
or mythological worldview,
a number of dramatic occurrences have unfolded,
we’ve become much more technologically powerful,
right.
The application of a strict empirical model
designed to abstract out from everyone’s
experience,
those things that are material and constant
have enabled us to produce
technological implements of extreme power,
right, both for good, at least in principle
with regards to medical advances,
and also for ill, in terms of our ability
to control weapons of unbelievable destructive
force.
So we’re more powerful. Are we any smarter
or any wiser?
Well I think a casual glance at the history
of the 20th Century would suggest that perhaps
we’re not.
I don’t think there’s any indication whatsoever,
although perhaps things have improved in the
last fifteen years,
that an additional consequence of our capacity
to extract ourselves from our religious modes
of thought
has been a palpable increase in wisdom or
tolerance or compassion,
or a palpable increase in our ability to understand
explicitly what might constitute the basis
for a suitable and stable state.
So you might take, for example, the fact that
the 20th Century has been unbelievably bloody,
right, literally hundreds of millions of people
killed in conflicts of one form or another,
both external, say, in the course of World
War II or Vietnam,
and internal, in the case of Nazi Germany
or the Soviet Union,
or any of the vast array of countries who
subjected their citizens to terrible internal
repression
in the name of the maintenance of order.
I mentioned that Alexander Solzhenitzyn estimated
that
sixty million people died in the Soviet Union
between 1919 and 1959
as a consequence of internal repression,
and his estimates were that perhaps twice
that many died during the Cultural Revolution
in China.
Looking back on the 20th Century, one seem,
one thing seems relatively clear, right.
Although humanity as a whole has ceased, or
had ceased at least to engage in large scale
religious conflicts,
although they seem to have been making a vicious
comeback in the last five years,
our ability to live together still seems incredibly
compromised by our capacity to engage in ideological
conflict, right,
and it doesn’t seem to me ridiculous to
presume that the battles between capitalism
and communism, say,
or between capitalism, communism and fascism
, or even the emergent struggle between fundamentalist
Islam and the West,
can necessarily be regarded as anything but
extensions of our tendency towards religious
and mythological conflict,
even though, in principle, systems like communism
and fascism were not predicated on explicitly
religious presuppositions.
Well it seems to me that a logical conclusion
from observations of that sort
is that even if you eradicate the traditional
trappings of the mythological worldview,
which seems to be what’s happened as a consequence
of our rise in empirical knowledge,
that you don’t eradicate the tendency for
people to formulate groups, belief systems
, around conceptions of ways that you should
behave
that are, at the very least, religious in
structure and action, even if they’re not
religious in name;
I mean I think it’s a very peculiar coincidence,
for example,
that the Soviet Communists erected at Male
Trinity
Marx, Lenin and Stalin as an apparent replacement
for the masculine trinity
that comprised the essential deities of Orthodox,
Russian Orthodox Christianity.
Why would these forms re-emerge so spontaneously,
and what does it mean that people who regard
themselves as essentially modern and empirical
in their presuppositions seem to be absolutely
susceptible in their fundament to ideological
claims?
Well if you look at the Soviet Union, which
I think is a very instructive case
because the Soviets, the Russians, were really
the last European power to fall prey to the
conflict
between empiricism and science and religion,
and they didn’t really fall prey to that
until the mid 1800’s
because Russia was a relatively closed society,
relatively illiterate,
maintaining a medieval structure far past
the time when other European countries had
abandoned that.
In the 1850’s, a wave of atheism spread
across Russia,
in some sense as a wave of enlightenment,
but also as a plague,
and figures as powering as Tolstoy
remembered in his memoirs the very day that
he realized
that the empirical discoveries of Western
Europeans had eradicated his ability to believe
in the Russian Orthodox system.
You lose something like that, what happens?
Well if you believe that mythological thinking
is nothing but superstitious empiricism
and that it’s been replaced entirely by
a more appropriate modern view, then nothing
happens, right,
it’s all to your benefit to become enlightened,
but if you believe that there’s more to
the story than that,
and that more traditional, ethical and moral
systems predicated on mythological presuppositions
offer you a map of how to behave and what
to think and how to regulate your emotions
and what to strive for,
none of which can be replaced by a scientific
perspective, then the eradication of a system
like that leaves a vacuum,
and then the question is, what rushes in to
fill a vacuum?
Well if you look at the case of the Soviet
Union, it seems quite instructive, doesn’t
it.
I mean, there’s a thirty-year period where
there’s tremendous intellectual clash,
say between a materialist, an empirical perspective,
and in Russian Orthodox perspective.
The Russian Orthodox perspective loses its
attractiveness for the reigning intellectual
elite
and the presuppositions of communism which
appear rational by contrast,
but which, by all evidence, were not, rush
in to fill the gap, and
I want to read you something that Nietzsche
wrote, it’s perhaps the most famous thing
he ever said,
although it’s almost entirely taken out
of context and misquoted, and if not misquoted,
at least misunderstood,
because Nietzsche was one of these strange
people who was capable of living 50 or even
100 years into the future,
and although he was, is, generally regarded
as an enemy of Christianity and superstition,
and was certainly an unbelievably outspoken
of Christian… opponent of Christian traditionalism,
he also knew that if you let the old Gods
die,
the probability that blood would flood the
land was virtually 100%,
so let me read you what he wrote with respect
to precisely this point:
Have you not heard of that mad man who lit
a lantern in the bright morning hours, ran
to the marketplace and cried incessantly,
I seek God. As many of those who do not believe
in God were standing around just then, he
provoked must, much laughter. Why, did he
get lost, said one. Did he lose his way like
a child, said another, or is he hiding, is
he afraid of us, is he going on a voyage or
emigrated, thus they yelled and laughed. The
mad man jumped into their midst and pierced
them with his glances. Wither is God, he cried,
I shall tell you. We have killed him, you
and I. All of us are his murderers. But how
have we done this, how were we able to drink
up the sea, who gave us the sponge to wipe
away the entire horizon, what did we do when
we unchanged this earth from its sun? Wither
is it moving now? Wither are we moving now?
Away from all suns? Are we not plunging continuously
backwards, sideward, forward, in all directions?
Is there any up or down left? Are we not straying
as though through an infinite nothing, did
we not feel the breath of empty space, has
it not become colder, is not night and more
night coming on all the while, must not lanterns
be lit in the morning, do we not hear anything
yet of the noise of the grave diggers who
are burying God, do we not smell anything
yet of God’s decomposition? Gods, too, decompose.
God is dead, God remains dead, and we have
killed him. How shall we, the murderer of
all murderers, comfort ourselves? What was
holiest and most powerful of all that the
world has yet owned has bled to death under
our knives. Who will wipe this blood off us?
What water is there for us to clean ourselves,
what festivals of atonement, what sacred game
shall we have to invent? Is not the greatness
of this deed too great for us? Must we not
ourselves become God simply to seem worthy
of it?
Well as you can tell,
that’s a much different notion from the
casual God is dead quotation
that’s most generally associated with Nietzsche
. Well what is he saying? Well he’s saying
something like this:
A system like Christianity,
or any system that’s con, that’s oriented
a society for thousands and thousands of years
can’t simply be, be eradicated by a casual
gesture without consequences ensuing in its
aftermath.
What consequences?
Well Nietzsche says, well we’ll no longer
know up from down.
What does he mean by that, metaphorically?
Well up, that’s where you’re headed, right?
And down, that’s what you want to stay away
from,
and when you eradicate the most fundamental
presuppositions of your system of values,
then there is no up and there is no down,
and then where are you precisely? Well it’s
not so easy, it’s not so easy to say, having
not necessarily ever been in that position.
What is your life like when you don’t know
up from down? Is it merely neutral?
Is, is there merely no value left, or could
it possibly be the case that if up and down
have both been eradicated,
that the place that you’re left in is something
much more akin to a permanent state of suffering,
because maybe it’s only the case that the
constant capacity to strive for up,
and being an up that you believe in,
the constant striving for up is actually what
makes your life normal to you,
and if you lost the sense of up and down,
the place that you would end up would be not
so much neutral as terrible.
Now if you have any belief system at all,
you do this, so let’s say you’re an advocate
of left wing politics,
you take a pro-environmental stance, or an
anti-corporate stance,
which is a relatively common thing to do among
undergraduates.
What do you do when you hold that belief system?
You view the world as it lays itself out,
and you explain the manner in which it manifests
itself in terms of the axioms of that belief
system,
and you may know that you can do it, right,
you can tell a credible story about why the
world is the way it is
by adopting, say, an anti-corporate perspective,
because there are all sorts of terrible things
about the world
that are a consequence, say, of corporate
maneuvering,
and you might also say that, and Piaget would
say this,
that it’s a necessary developmental stage
to acquire allegiance to a given belief system.
Why?
Well any up is better than none, that might
be the first observation,
so even if your belief system is relatively
insufficient and easily challenged on intellectual
grounds
and perhaps not very complete anyways, the
fact that it does lay out a moral structure
and tell you good from evil and right from
wrong, that’s a, that’s a plus, that’s
an advantage.
Now it’s relative intellectual weakness
and it’s incoherence assuming it, it is
incoherent to some degree, that’s a flaw,
but that doesn’t mean that the effort to
establish a system like that is worthless;
is because they felt that the order Hitler
promised repressive as it was,
was preferable to the chaos that was likely
to ensue in its absence.
What is it about chaos that’s so terrifying?
Second Nietzsche said: adopting a belief system
of any sort and imposing coherency on the
viewing it through the lens of that explicit
system disciplines your mind.
So for example
to live in the absence of any stated beliefs
is hardly to live at all.
To live in the presence of a narrow minded
and extreme belief system
is at least to undergo the rigors both behavioral
and intellectual
of coming to terms with the world from some
perspective.
Nietzsche said the reason the modern mind
such as it is
was able to free itself from the past at all
was because it had first thoroughly
as a consequence of that subordination to
then break free of it.
In all science of morals so far one thing
was lacking strange as it may sound the problem
of morality itself.
What was lacking was any suspicion that there
was something problematic here.
Every society every functioning individual
every functioning family every social unit
has a moral code.
But they differ. So what does that mean exactly
what, it’s complicated isn't it because
the fact of the universality of the code
the fact of the code indicates that the code
or a code is necessary.
By the same token the fact that there's a
multiplicity of codes seems to suggest
that the particulars of a given code aren't
necessarily relevant
and so Nietzsche says brilliantly I think
we’re faced with a problem.
No life without morality - no absolute morality.
What do we do?
One of the things Jung observed was that if
you look at the structure of stories
we thought first there's a relationship between
stories and moral codes.
Well seems relatively straightforward doesn’t
it.
You tell a simple story like a parable sometimes
they're complex too like an Aesop’s fable
say.
What do you extract out from the story? A
moral.
and that person does better or worse and the
moral of the story is if you act in this manner
you will do better or worse.
Proverbial knowledge.
We all tell stories.
They have identifiable structure you can tell
that because the movie studio in Hollywood
can produce a movie and people all over the
world will watch it
people all over the world all over the world
tell stories to one another.
The plot elements seem similar. Are the morals
similar?
That’s a more difficult question, right,
we know that the details of morality can vary
from culture to culture,
is there anything that doesn’t vary from
culture to culture?
Why would you wanna find that?
Well Alexander Solzhenitsyn thought that one
of the most important occurrences of the 20th
century
were the Nuremberg trials.
The Nuremberg trials brought the perpetrators
of the Nazi genocide to justice
and that’s easy to be cynical about that
and perhaps you should be cynical about it
and so of course the losers were going to
be tried from the perspective of the winner’s
moral code
but Solzhenitsyn says well wait you know there's
something more to this story at least there
seems to be
in that many of the events that characterized
the Nazi atrocities
were so awful, outside of intellectual argumentation,
because you can provide an intellectual argument
for anything
they were so awful that the proper visceral
embodied response of any observer
regardless of specific moral code should be
repugnant. Period. Such that encoded at least
initially in international law
genocide is a crime against humanity. Right.
No matter what the particulars of your moral
code.
So goes the logic. You cannot construct a
viable moral code that enables genocide,
if not a logical impossibility and I think
it is a logical impossibility
it’s an ethical impossibility.
And then you have to ask yourself, and this
is not precisely an intellectual question,
does that seem credible to you.
Does it seem credible that there are acts
that are so terrible
that no one regardless of their stated position
should ever engage in them.
And if the answer is yes then I would say
well if you haven't moved towards personal
accept acceptance of an ultimate "up”
so to speak you’ve certainly identified
at least one "down" that you don’t want
to approach.
And that’s the beginnings of the establishment
of some notion of absolute moral authority.
So what if we said, hypothetically something
like this.
Let’s say that morality isn't a philosophy,
it’s not something explicit, something implicit.
How does it evolve?
Well emotional creatures produce it,
you don’t have to produce it in isolation
if you were weren't a social animal i
if you lived a solitary and nocturnal existence,by
yourself
there's no need for morality because you don’t
have to regulate your behaviour
with regards to your peers but you're social
animals so you're stuck with everybody else
but everybody else could be conceived us as
a grand average right.
How would you act towards the average person.
I would say that very, very stable moral systems
tell you exactly that and the say things like:
do unto others as you would have them do unto
you. Right? Basic principle of reciprocity.
it who knows
is distributed sanity you don’t have to
be that sane, as long as you're hanging around
other people
because as soon as you do something that’s
deviant they're gonna raise an eyebrow at
you
and the you think oh well. Not that.
And as soon as you do something good then
they're gonna pay more attention and smile
at you
so all of the information about how to regulate
yourself is out there in the world right,
the averaged person.
How many people do you interact with in a
week? 300 say maybe it’s not that many,
100.
How about in a year, thousand, 2000, 5000,
10,000 what are they all telling you?
Well the message is similar across people.
How similar. Don’t know exactly how similar
but that’s what stories tell you how similar.